hello there citizens of the reject Nation we
are going to watch The Last of Us episode 8
today I'm assuming the David chapter we are
here joined with Andrew Gordon Agor 7-11
how are you I'm good almost as good as your biceps
but yes I'm excited to see the David episode uh
because I thought he was one of the best written
characters in the game so I'm looking forward to
seeing what we're gonna get that's great my biceps
let's talk about that you know why they look good
today because of this shirt ShopZeroEdition.com
this is a real rejects exclusive Last of Us
inspired shirt and don't worry if you haven't
played the game there is not a single part of
the game where Joel and Ellie are doing the Shawn
of the Dead ending guys with that in mind go ahead
and leave a like that would mean a lot wouldn't
Andrew I think they should also subscribe and
click that notification Bell get notified when
our reaction for the finales Rob is that right
Andrew I think you should also by the way full
interaction watch alongs where you sync it with
your own copy available for super sexy rejects
over our patreon page we cover stuff exclusively
over there reaction highlights and watch
alongs included Andrew shut up let's get to it
revelation 21.
sure
and I heard a great voice
out of Heaven saying behold
and God shall wipe away all tears from their eyes
wipe her tears away
do you remember what
Jesus killed the clickers
and God will wipe away all
tears from their eyes do you know what that means
he's so creepy his Cadence does sound a lot like
the original voice actor Noah North yeah the
ground is too cold to dig we'll bury your father
in the spring bless you we'll get through this
oh we're gonna get to know his people they're
human too they're not just horrible individuals
humanizing everyone even Josiah and Martin
think they spotted some deer the other night
it was dark see what you want to see sometimes
James
yeah it's Joe I sensed out in there like Thomas
I still believe it's been uh the last six
months have been hard here is Joe voice peeking
through now go get our guns we're going hunting
he said making part of David's team
that's interesting he's thirsty
why this does feel biblical
oh
yeah look at her eye on the gun gotta get some
food it's cool seeing the
precursor yeah I like this
oh no bow narrow stop comparing it to the
game I'm sorry I didn't mean to compare it
wow I love that they shot this on location yes
I'm gonna miss the show all right
oh
that is freezing
sounds like a clicker but
I would assume it's a deer
which you'll touch you that deer is an [__] oh
the blood trail yeah
what do you think
I don't see anybody you think we can
just take it don't drop your rifles
turn and face me slow any sudden moves I put
one right between your eyes you know for Buddy
boys I won't say it twice please just 10 seconds
we're not asking for charity we we can trade you
for some of the deer we have
what do you need we have medicine
like for infections not not for a bite
follow us I'm not following you anywhere
where buddy boy can go get it
right between my eyes bring back two bottles and
a syringe it's not code James do as I said wink
you look badass a while before James gets
back I have some oil and matches in my package
take shelter him with us
starting this off with leaning in on him
being a pastor makes this a very different
kind of dynamic the Optics around it just
yeah they hit you differently they did hint
at it in the game but yes I agree you know you
really shouldn't be out here all on your own
from where I'm sitting you shouldn't be at
her on your own for what it's worth there's
room for you in our group if you want any
inviting me to your hunger Club thanks
I'm a decent man trying to take care of the
people who rely on me they chose to follow you
weird cult thing good question I am a
preacher what the whole world ended and
you still believe that [__] I actually
started believing after the world ended
kids about your age so he went from teacher
to preacher because what it [__] rhymes
well I found God after the apocalypse
which is either the best time or the
worst time to find him hard to say yeah and
as we wanted we picked up new people along
the way until we ended up here we look
at you right now sooner or later luck
no such thing as luck no I I believe
everything happens for a reason
sure we didn't expect this winner to be so cruel
game's been hard to find so I sent four of our
people to a nearby Town ah they're skipping it
only three of them came back and the one that
didn't was a father he had a daughter just
like you and her dad was taken from her ice
he was murdered by this crazy man that
crazy man was traveling with a little girl
everything happens for a
reason James lower the gun
man did you bring the
medicine yeah throw it to her
David
it's Joel why are you telling
to back away and protect you
I'm so sad they skipped it don't compare
right now you'll have to adjust Andrew
Joe where the [__] do I put this
Gamble
oh
so sweet
yeah that's what I'm thinking too huh what is it
do they not know whether I don't know seems
like they keep it hidden from the people
oh they just brought the deer in big one
oh did you tell them yes we found a girl
who was with the man who took Alec from us
Rises I'll lead a group out to pick up her Trail
interesting we'll bring that man to Justice
you kill him you should kill both of them this
is really interesting yeah yeah wow I got so many
thoughts about this because that's definitely
setting up quite something that I can't spoil
ah dude
the truth is Hannah you will always have a father
who will show him respect when he's speaking here
creep yeah
thank you
I know this is Icky oh this is disturbing itself
are they eating hat I think so
yeah that's despicably gross
I really like the Sinister additions though not
gonna lie it's awesome and they are
springboarding a lot of thoughts
callus
do you have a weapon Ally can we bring that girl
back with us she's just another mouth to feed
leave her out here she'll die yeah maybe that's
God's will oh no he's not a Believer smack him
question
me that's a gunshot there are men coming
okay I'm gonna leave them away from you
but if anybody makes it down here she can kill
them you got it this is dead do not fall asleep
oh
Alice
oh nice shot done
oh callous I got her
die
do it
oh no
I want Justice for Alec two
of you with me the rest of
you stay here go door to door you
so hungry for vengeance deliver it
what a creep yeah it's good though got a
great actor for this role yeah it's great
come on Joel John Wicked their asses
yeah this guy got lucky on the first try oh we
don't know how many houses he visited before
nicely done
look up in the eyes watch his soul leave
oh damn he died or not really
devilish way yeah painful too
this sounds creepy the sound
design in this episode is splendid
point to this map
one line from this scene I want just one and
I think you know what it is why am I in a cage
because I'm afraid of you you're a dangerous
person you've certainly proven that
I can see how much you care about him but even
so you better face reality you gotta face reality
dick that part of your life it's ending and what
I'm offering you is a beginning but if you can't
find a way to trust me then yes you are alone
it's not a great start to the trust building
guys need manscape products foreign
Silver Lake
it's a resort a resort
I'm so happy they're doing this they're in the
point to where we are and where your Resort is
yes it better be the exact same
to spot your buddy points too
I've never been so happy to see such a messed up
scene go ask him he'll tell you I'm not lying yeah
I ain't telling you [__] okay I believe him
yes oh yes so happy so happy very well delivered
oh
Rosie gross gross gross for what it's
worth this is just dear meat I swear
I'd rather not
well yes we all are that's sort of the point
yeah Fair it was a last resort you think it
doesn't shame me that would be my first Resort let
them starve these people who put their lives in
my hands I don't think your friend would either
didn't he take another man's life to save yours
around for the context David and you
know what I see when I look at you
I've always had a violent heart
I struggled with it for a long time then the
world ended and I was shown the truth my God
cordyceps huh it's fruitful it multiplies feeds
and protects its children it secures
its future with violence if it must
yes he loves I'm a Shepherd surrounded
by sheep and all I want is an equal
I can tell the others to stop looking
for him they'll spare him really
just let him go yeah they follow me and they
would follow us Lord knows I could use the help
we grow spread out and we do whatever we needed
for our people imagine the life we could build
let's see when I go tell the others now
Ellie what tell them that Ellie is a little girl
who broke her [__] yes that's all I wanted
Bella Ramsay you are awesome she better get
a nomination I swear to God the real God
not this false god David really the
cordyceps God damn look at this man
oh
foreign
look at it
dude this episode has a great
grip on build what did you say
no she would have turned by now
this isn't real pretty [__]
ah Troy Baker oh poor Troy [__] Troy Baker man
oh I know which part we're at
oh boy
part always freaked me out
oh yeah
damnation
belly Ellie
Ellie that he's so creepy no one
infected fights this hard to stay alive
that's a Philippians quote no one likes being
humiliated Ellie you don't know how good I am
you see I changed my mind
decided you do need a father
oh crazy shot oh
I thought you already knew the
fighting is a part I like the most oh
don't be afraid there's no fear in love
oh
God
ah okay
okay okay baby girl
ah we that is paced so well though
radio so listen we're gonna have to do this review
a little different we decided very early on that
um we're gonna need a spoiler section all
right we just we just need one because
there's especially some implementation they had
in this episode and I'm like I just I have to
talk so we're gonna not go into spoilers
right now uh but we'll just stick to here
however there's going to be some stuff that
talks about the future specifically regarding
uh the second game that I think is would be
good to touch on but um I I thought this was
an excellent episode I really did I thought
it was excellent you know it like there are
I don't want to spend too much time backtracking
to some other episodes this did that thing go
where yeah they did cut out some stuff that would
have been cool to bring to the big screen but they
also added in a lot of things and expanded upon
that I thought made it for taking this section
of the game that is very they obviously they have
to condense it down but it didn't feel rushed to
me or like a short film version I thought it was a
perfectly packaged you know uh piece that they had
to do in order to tell this chapter which I think
is really integral to the development of Ellie uh
especially because of just the the depth she has
to ultimately go to in order to survive you know
like you she's a Survivor like anyone else but
this is the first time where you see her unleash
unleash a violent side of herself that you never
get to see prior you know like you get the sense
that maybe she ended up killing Riley after Riley
turned you know um in this show she hasn't killed
any humans yet right am I right about that uh she
I think she shot a few people but like actually
hand-to-hand combat I believe this is her first
one yeah this is because this is like brutal I
should kill two people in this episode you know
she shot a few people yeah yeah and you watch
like sort of this this morphing process and
also would Joel having a rescue her like this
is a real pivotal turning point for both of these
characters and you can just sort of see it in the
emotions and I thought they did an excellent job
on bringing that to life uh I I thought it was
like yeah David's great and all uh well I do want
to talk more about him I was really impressed with
the way this episode was paced because it was
it starts off with like really deliberate and
the pace just kept ramping up and kept going and
going and going and then the way they handled
especially the reveal of David like what I
thought was cool about because if you guys
haven't played the game when they introduce him
they introduce him when Ellie's about to grab
the deer that's the first introduction and it's
immediately kind of I don't know about this guy
you know but then some stuff happens in the game
that they do not have here that makes you go oh
maybe he's actually an all right guy and then
you find out no he's not he's an all right guy
so I thought they had the a neat effect here
where when they introduce him you're like oh
he's a he's a caretaker he loves his people he's
there's something warm about him he's a family man
so when she when they meet Ellie you're like
no no no this is one of the good guys you
know of course I've played the game but but
in the context here I imagine if I had him
play the game but yes no he's one of the good
guys he's one of the all right guys come on
and then he's they slowly start to peel the
back yeah like oh never mind oh never mind oh
wow really never mind this this guy snapped in the
apocalypse there you know uh and I thought they
did a really excellent job where a lot of the tone
was driven by the drive to save Ali the drive to
protect Joel and of course the um the end like I
don't even call it transformation more of the the
unveiling of David I thought it was instrumented
like very very well so yeah but Andrew you didn't
get your scene that you wanted I'm sorry oh yeah
yeah well we'll talk about that in a sec I did
think again as you just mentioned this episode was
extremely well paced minus the scene I didn't want
um bastards Andrew yeah but again you know what
even though I was definitely I was disappointed
by that there have been others I mean you made a
great point that the stuff that they did include
did make up for it although I really still wear it
like the reason I think that scene is so pivotal
important at least for me yes I get it in the game
it was an action sequence so you're in control
so it's like important but I also feel it's just
so important because it shows that Ellie is just
obviously yes I get to we get to see Ellie you
know later on in this episode where she survives
on her own and she does take care of David of
course I mean we get that in the game as well but
just seeing her fend off for herself on her own
when you know a bunch of infected are coming after
like seeing that side of belly it's just it's I
don't know it just for me it was it was just such
an important and integral part of the game and
for Ellie's character just fleshing her out more
and I was a little bit sad not to see it I
I get why they didn't put it in although I
again I I wish like even five minute sequence of
of that action sequence would have made me even
happy but again you can't get everything but you
know the thing that this show has not just this
episode but this whole show Even though there
have been action sequences that to my sadness
have not been included the characters have been
absolutely I mean we talked about this before off
camera the character the characters have just been
nailed perfectly for the most part just across the
board absolutely now then if I had to choose one
thing I have the action sequences on my video game
whenever I want so I know I can always go to that
would it be cool to see visually of course I do I
wish they were here absolutely but if you if I had
to pick what you were gonna nail on an on-screen
adaptation I I would choose the characters because
I do have that action sequence and I can play it
at home so I'm glad that they are nailing the
character-wise maybe hey maybe season two we
will get some more action sequences that we didn't
get here you never know but again I I it did make
me feel a little better when you mentioned
yeah that's true we did get some inclusions
that we didn't get in the game that make up for
not getting that action sequence and there were
some stuff that they had in there like the Ellie
you know tell them that Ellie's a little girl that
broke your finger like I'm so glad they they kept
that in there and I loved uh belly's delivery in
that moment it was and it nailed the the tone of
what Ashley Johnson was going to we got Troy Baker
of course I really like that actor a lot that
they got for David I really feel like he just
nailed the mannerisms and the tone and that that
slimy yet he feels almost like a good guy telling
to the reveal kind of happens with of David that
Nolan North really encompassed in the video game
just really solid job by that I realized Nolan
North played him yeah it was never I didn't
realize that it was known North so uh yeah yeah
no so I thought that actor really nailed it again
and very very well paced episode some really cool
action sequences that we did get that carried on
from the game um overall yeah really good episode
I love the locations I love that they actually
went on you know location to film in some of
these people in in Colorado or where did they
film in Vancouver I believe it looks like all
right it does look like Colorado I think it was
Vancouver wherever it was I'm glad they got to go
in the cinematography on the show is so top-notch
um I think my my two favorite moments of this
episode were when Ellie was kind of like you
know holding Joel in the bed like just saying with
him like just like it was such a yeah tender and
such a bonding moment just I don't maybe that
happened in the game I I'd have to reply yeah
yeah either way I love that and then one of my
favorite moments in the game that Pedro Pasco just
absolutely nailed the line where he calls her baby
girl like that's really yeah we've had moments
of building and fleshing out of like yes I'm
accepting this this girl as my surrogate daughter
from just the scenes where he's been so protective
of her but actually hearing him call her baby
girl like that it just it's such a such a deep and
amazing like moment the delivery by Pedro Pascal I
just it's one of my favorite moments in the game
when Joel is so accepting yet yes I can do the
protective stuff but actually calling her and like
being accepting that this is my daughter now like
I'm ready to to face that that fact like I just
loved and again Pedro Pascal I just loved it and
of course the interrogation scene like absolutely
Perfection with that scene like that was so
freaking perfect I mean Pedro Pascal like you talk
about belly getting nominated which I agree she
just she absolutely deserves it he better get
freaking nominated for for this show like his
performance I think he's secured it yeah I think
he has he's so good I I feel like Pedro Pascal is
gonna this might sound weird I don't ever put
out a prediction like this I think he's gonna
win sexiest man alive in 2023. he has to right
it's just like I mean there's like a Renaissance
yeah he's he's awesome yeah and then also too
in regards to Ellie like seeing what happens
to her character seeing the transformation
she's like she basically you know when David
violates her like that and she she really to
me she loses a piece of her soul and a piece
of her innocence and it's just interesting seeing
that transformation how we see it in the game and
how you know Bella Ramsay was able to really show
that the the facial expressions and like I could
really feel like that like watching her on screen
like just where you feel a piece of her soul is
gone like that innocence is gone and you see that
Rage carryover which we're going to talk about a
little when we get to the spoiler section how that
rage carries on over and so it's just yeah no it's
a it's a really tender and crazy moment for the
character that she has to go through I mean yeah
David is a I just think David is in the game and
especially here too it's just such a well-written
villain yeah he is I think Ellie in that scene is
like reborn in fire you know yeah and they they
do an excellent job which demonstrate like the
this chapter is so important because this is this
is when you see Joel really sick like get ugly he
gets ugly and ruthless yeah and then you see Ellie
having to do that as well in order to survive
you know they there there comes an understanding
between the two of them and I think when you talk
about action scenes not being included the element
that I think would help would have helped Aid this
is the the part is like I don't it's not just that
I want more gameplay sequences included because
I'm I really don't ever think about that too much
like I was I was okay with missing it however it
the one part of this world that I think could use
a like going into season two that could help aid
it is you know when you're in the game when you're
walking around it's always scary because you just
never go like what the hell there's some something
might be at any corner like you just never know
and here I never really get the sense that we're
ever in danger of infected being around it's like
you you kind of always know you're kind of always
when in fact they're going to show up you're aware
like okay this is an infected scene that's about
to happen as opposed to feeling like a constant
looming threat in any direction you know and
that that was the sequence that they that they X
out of this this episode so I do I do think that
that is an element to the world of The Last of Us
that ought to be so it's not really so much about
I want action scenes or anything it's really I
want that threat feeling I want that threat kind
of permeating throughout uh the experience yeah
you know also the fact to yes we know David is a
pedophile and you know like he wants he wants
Ellie around to be like his pet and we we get
that and I understand but I just felt like two
in the game in that action sequence like that
that whole action sequence just did a good job
of building like why David wants her around like
after seeing what she can do exactly I get what
you're getting because I did have that thought
um where like the part where I would agree with
having that action scene is because when David's
like I see this in you I'm like you guys like
you just passed a conversation yeah yeah and
yes like while while there is you know a much
more disgusting uh quality to David uh a much
more deviant side to David you you do get why
he would think that that others you get why he
would also buy into the other stuff is that just
saying it to take advantage of her yeah there's
also this side where he he can't see it because
he saw the kind of War but then again like with
with the game the sequence of events plays out
a little different because like they do the
three-month time like Joel's is it three months
like Joel's been like it was fall to winter so
Joel's been healing for a long time yes right um
and we did the winter no no we we started winter
a little bit earlier on the show whereas in
winter like it literally starts right where
the rabbit is in the bone arrow that's really
where it starts we got our winter jump after
Henry and Sam correct so a little bit earlier
on the show and we get but in the game you get
the winter jump uh after Joel and leave Tommy and
I'll end the and Jackson after they leave there
he's been in the game he's been healing yes
up for a few months yeah and that's how I was
able whereas here it's like I don't know this
just all occurred within a few days right and
like that that's So within that you get Ellie
who's been hunting and providing for them so
she's developed skills and whatnot to to be
able to survive on her own and hunt down prey
so like that quality to building her up
I think I think when it comes to season
two we're gonna just do a big time jump
again like following the the second game
um of how things progress but anyway yeah yeah
I'm trying to watch my words yeah but also too
if you if you notice like right when the episodes
started and we hadn't even seen David I said is he
a pasture or like I was thinking the reason
I said that is because I'm sure many of you
noticed in the video game I'm not sure if you
did this that action sequence that I was really
sad and that we didn't get to see when they're
warding off all the clickers and the infected
and of course the bloater David does say like he
makes like a kind of a prayer did you ever did
you ever notice that or hear that or no because
I I'd always know yeah like off to the side it's
not like a very focal point but off to the side
he kind of makes like a prayer and I was always
I always think in my head whenever I'd see him do
that because I'd always noticed I'm like yeah was
he a priest was he a pastor like he's very like
I feel like there's something religious here so
that's why in the beginning I was like I wonder if
they're gonna go that route and then when I heard
that I was like oh that's why I was thinking that
so I was glad that they did expand upon that from
the game I had a feeling we were possibly going
to go there um but also too I remember that line
in the game where he said oh we're all starving
women children I always thought that was kind
of a lying line that he was just trying to get
Ellie's trust so actually seeing it here like I
mean yeah he was trying to get her trust but it's
like no he act actually we're women and children
who were starving so it was like there was I
mean kind of humanizes and I know we were kind
of making a joke we're humanizing the cannibals
now too like we gotta humanize everyone well they
do specify that not everyone here is aware of
what they're consuming I think I think you know
Troy Baker brought a lot to this role yeah he was
great as James I I thought he brought so you could
feel like the history in his eyes and these little
exchanges of being like yeah David's my leader but
there's so much parts in the exchanges like they
have that thing where he calls him out for being
doubtful yeah and you could see that he he doubts
the way the leadership has progressed in the path
they've had to go down he's even like there's
even this this hardened part of himself when it
comes to his time to eat the food oh yeah another
body language yeah for sure where he doesn't want
to do it but he's like this is my life now you
know and I I there is uh there's um there is a
level of there's a big level of Gravitas to what
he bring the pathos is more of the word I would
say for what Troy Baker brought to this specific
portrayal like I'm like damn there's a he really
yeah really bright he's not just here for like a
cami like this is a real role like he's a body no
he's great I mean yeah yeah he said that there was
that one line or so where it kind of sounded like
the Joel voices coming out a little bit but no I
agree with you and if I didn't know what was going
to happen because I remember what happened to his
character James in the video game which I knew was
gonna happen here uh with Ellie taking the butcher
knife to his neck after tricking them that she's
been infected I really thought too they did a good
job of setting up the audience who had not played
the game of kind of like yeah he's losing faith
in David like there's a good chance David might
execute him at some point too like they were
really doing a good job of like setting that
up for the audience who has not played the video
games because I mean even though I knew that was
kind of I was like I almost feel like they might
stray away from the game and go that route just
because of how much like he's calling him kind
of calling him out and just lost faith in him
and like David can't show weakness in leadership
so I just I thought that was interesting that they
were doing that so I really think they did a great
job on slowly pulling back the layers of David yes
I thought that was like that the actor too was
perfectly sync with right with the script yeah
and the direction of knowing of how much more of
his evil has to be unveiled per scene I can see
the complaints now though about him right now on
the internet if there are any he doesn't look like
David from the video game I don't know I don't I'm
still a white guy and I still got a white guy yeah
exactly no I mean I personally like I said he
nailed the mannerisms of no and and he sounded
very similar to Nolan North uh and again I just
love how they peeled black and flush the character
out even more expanded upon the character is the
word and I love how they again expanded upon just
the whole town as a whole and just showed David
as a leader I just thought all that stuff was
really it was very meticulous and very interesting
well the the way they also unveil the way he deals
with his own faith of its manipulation tactic
and he's really succumbed to the worship of the
cordyceps yes as that is his new deity I thought
that was a really fascinating layer that was
um this apocalyptic worship you know it was those
are crazy inclusion and like I I I'm surprised we
don't have anything like that in the game like
there's not of both games there's nothing about
that in the in either of the game well I mean Neil
druckman has always said if we can improve upon
anything from the game I mean if we're gonna if we
stay faithful again we're going to stay faithful
the game but there's something we can improve upon
we're gonna do it whether it's faithful or not so
now I definitely I I'm glad they've adopted
adapted to that method like the cordyceps are
our new Lords you know that's interesting yeah
yeah it's it's a fascinating version of being
an apostle in this situation yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah exactly yeah obviously no no one who
hasn't played uh yes will understand that but
yes I agree with you I but guys um yeah we're
going to talk about some spoilery stuff right now
so if you haven't played thank you for being here
bye shirt uh if if you if you don't want to hear
anything about what more than likely will come up
uh then because I I think when playing this game
before I go to spoilers but I think when playing
this section when I when I there's choices in the
second game that very much upset the audience yeah
I wonder what you're talking about and when I
played the second game for the first time when
those choices first presented themselves like I
love the second game I preferred over the first
um but when those choices first presented
themselves I I remember being upset however when I
replayed both the first game and the second game
like pretty much right away it was this chapter
that made me go oh no wait this flows really well
now into the second game like I'm not upset at all
by the choice because this chapter really sets
that up and then this episode made it even more
of a setup that I went oh what an interesting way
to condense it down instead of a bunch of hunters
he kills to just one guy so that's what I'm gonna
talk about here so I would click off right now uh
if you made it this far but yeah um for those who
played the second game or at least are aware of
what happens in it is that Joel is killed by Abby
and why is because without going into every single
detail Abby's father was murdered by Joel Dr Jerry
Anderson and now here there bringing that over
here in a way that is like a setup yeah for what
is to come because when I played the game when you
get to this section and you get all these people
who are hunting down Joel they want Joel's head
it was already to me telegraphing that oh people
are coming for Joel and Joel's going to die like
the first game was already saying that to us and
then you get to the second game you're like well
there it is people came for Joel and then they
made it even more more on the nose here by going
this girl's dad was killed by Joel We gotta find
this guy and kill him it is massive foreshadowing
oh for uh what I was thinking for for the second
game that I think because it's going to be hard
for people to swallow that who are not familiar
with the game it's going to be really hot like
people who are familiar game can already have it
there's already enough people have a hard time
with it you know I've also been reading so many
comments too that's saying they better change
up what they did in the second game like they're
not look how faithful this season has been like
dude you're not yeah you're not getting what you
want sorry I know Joel's dying yeah a thousand
percentage Yeah I mean Abby's going to get a
Joel in one we already know that so I mean you
know uh no I agree with you they clearly really
foreshadowed that here I mean I was thinking
that right when we mentioned that it was her dad
was in my head I was just going at this is total
Abby foreshadowing so I mean yeah it does show
that I mean if you remember to to that game for
anyone who played or watched the gameplay of what
happens you know Joel says to her likes why don't
you save whatever speech you got or whatever
he says like he knows there are consequences
to what he's done like he knows his life is
over in the Moment Like and Joel's accepting
of that he obviously he doesn't want him to die
but he's accepting like hey I know I've hurt a
lot of people in the past obviously it's you know
he's defending himself or surviving or whatever
the case may be but he knows he has killed a lot
of people and those people have families so again
he's very accepting of the fact that hey uh this
is clearly someone I've hurt in the past someone
is related to someone I don't know exactly who
but my life is over it is what it is it sucks but
it is what it is yeah I know but I I mean again
they did a good job of foreshadowing that here
so that even the people who are not going to be
happy with that can understand like hey it sucks
what's gonna happen but you understand like even
though it was clearly obviously self-defense and
what happens here what happens in the game again
people who are here you're already you already
know what happened it wasn't self-defense in
regard to when he kills Dr Jerry Anderson that
particular case was not self-defense whether
Abby was prone to know if that was self-defense
I mean it's really it doesn't matter at that
point or all she knows is her dad's dead and
she just wants the guy who killed her she's bent
on Revenge so I mean we go from that stage but
um in regards to this one again whether it's
self-defense or not it doesn't matter these you
know you are affecting other people's lives when
you kill someone and they've got a family member
and so again they did it like you said they
did a great job of foreshadowing that setting
that up whether people are going to like that
or not it it you know it's I I don't think it
matters uh what just matters is that it's executed
properly and you know I think we're all going to
be heartbroken and sad when that when that comes
I'm I am curious though obviously we know it's
going to happen in season two how early are you
gonna do that in season two like I hope it's the
opening scene first scene the first scene no no
but it's cut to Joel's head I mean because a lot
of these I mean the first couple episodes of this
season were really freaking long which I loved
um so I'm wondering like maybe episode three maybe
episode I don't know what I mean I'm very curious
to see how they're going to do that because again
like we've talked about Last of Us Part Two is
like five times longer than the first game so you
were able to do the first game in Nine episodes
I don't know if they're gonna have to split it up
in a couple of Seasons when we get to season two
or you're gonna have to do 18. I'm very curious
how they're gonna do all that because you are not
doing season two in Nine episodes like that's just
in my opinion that's just not happening not it not
at the length of episodes that we're getting here
in my opinion I mean what are your thoughts do
you think they're they're able to be able to do
season two in Nine episodes I think they can do
it in five I think all you got when I said that I
knew who's coming with it all you got to do is uh
focus on Abby I don't care to see healthy stories
just take it all from Abby's perspective but again
like I was talking about too like seeing the loss
of of Ellie's innocence and her soul basically I
mean you said being reborn in Fire and all
that which I agree with a lot of that rage
carries over into the second game so again you
talk about the foreshadowing what happened with
yeah you know the it's a very important chapter
yeah no I mean like but that's the thing like
when I just went straight into the second game
like where's all this pent-up energy coming from
with Ellie and then when I replayed both the
first and the second game back to back I'm like
ah okay this chapter is just so integral and
like where that violence and that rage just comes
around it's freaking David like got it out of her
so yeah no I I think part two is just I mean it's
a great game on its own but it just goes so much
better when you play it immediately after the
first game it does that's how I'd recommend for
people to play it like skip the first game just
go right you most people waited years and then
they played it you know exactly which yeah don't
affect the experience yeah all right guys well
that's it for today's episode uh what'd you think
about it did you like it did you love it leave
your thoughts down below subscribe follow Andrew
don't forget to buy a shirt don't forget to buy
don't forget to mention how cringe-worthy I was
Andrew pick any name watch it watch anything with
Gabriel and Dave's has ever been shouted out uh
Petty name any name I'll make it work let's
go with come on buddy go with Lance Lance door
Lance is uh like if there's some common facts we
know about Lance all right Canadian fella ah I'm
half Canadian did you know that are you I'm
half Canadian my father wow that's awesome no
um he's also a fi a firefighter and he's
got like a hot wife and a really cool kid
so what a lot of people don't know about
Lance though is that actually and I gotta
be very careful of my words here
he's not a very interesting man
he's actually quite dull the reason
why his woman loves him so much
let's just say he's got a really
big fire hose you know what I mean
I understood that reference and
uh he sent me photos now normally
I tell followers maybe you shouldn't be sending me
photos of those things because it's inappropriate
but boy did I keep asking for more from
Lance and he kept delivering the goods
sometimes in a actual fire situation they
don't even use what's on the fire truck
when they're not able to access a fire hydrant
they call upon Lance and he just unzips
and does his thing he has saved many lives
with with that fire hose of his so he sent
you the fire hose how about the ax his
helmet any any pictures of those as well
are we talking about the same thing are you
talking about it actual ax at a helmet or do
you mean a photo of his big ax whichever one you
want to use your imagination for yeah he sent me
a photo of an actual ax it was really cool it was
really sharp and made of uh it was red full of and
super sharp and uh the helmet as well he sent
me a physical one but the fire hose I'm talking
about is Ah that's what I thought no Lance is a
great guy there's more to him than his fire hose
I just want to know if the line from Batman
Forever was true when he said to Dr Chase
Meridian try firemen less to take off I just want
to know if that line is true Lance let us know
I think we both need some sleep